[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada 8 de marzo se conmemora el día
internacional de la mujer una fecha por
la reivindicación de nuestros derechos
en una lucha sostenida que busca la
igualdad este año en ellas hoy
homenajeamos a las que nos empoderan en
los entornos laborales aún tan
desiguales y tan a menudo escenarios de
vulnerabilidad veremos historias de 8
países y tendremos la opinión de
expertas comenzamos cúcuta es uno de los
principales puntos de entrada de
migrantes venezolanos a colombia entre
ellos hay miles de mujeres en situación
de vulnerabilidad y expuestos a la
explotación sexual incluidas actividades
de prostitución y de webcam para
informar a margo los sirios
valentina trabaja como modelo en una
plataforma web para adultos este oficio
es conocido como cambio y ha tomado auge
durante la pandemia es venezolana y
tiene 25 años lleva tres años viviendo
en cúcuta le dedique a este oficio ocho
horas al día durante seis días a la
semana
ok esta es la beta sa donde el trabajo
cada cuarto tiene un computador con
pantalla una cámara y un equipo de luces
entonces acá yo siempre traigo dejo la
lencería acá como para que se me haga
más fácil usar miles de usuarios siguen
a valentina cada día ella se parte de
las modelos exitosas de esta empresa
por lo general no los ve solo interactúa
con ellos vía chat para recibir
peticiones de posturas sexuales los
deseos de los usuarios varían que yo no
me siento bien no lo hago simplemente le
digo oye mira no yo no hago esto y está
respetando aunque bien buscar otra
personalidad ya entonces ahí quedan la
frontera entre webcam y prostitución es
muy delgada las asociaciones feministas
hablan de explotación sexual que se debe
a las particularidades de la ciudad
estamos en un territorio frontera las
mujeres que llegan al país son mujeres
migrantes y son las más vulnerables sin
desconocer las víctimas del conflicto
armado las mujeres empobrecidas
pero literal las mujeres migrantes en
este momento las niñas son las más
vulnerables
alejandra verá denuncia la existencia de
redes que involucran también a menores
de edad y a su juicio el trabajo de
mujer webcams sea similar a la
prostitución este día ella visita a
andrea una joven venezolana de 19 años
que llegó a cúcuta a los 15 y quien sin
más opción se inició en la prostitución
después fue mujer webcam andrea asegura
que las consecuencias psicológicas son
dramáticas como haciendo como
como humillada porque no creo que como
mujer tenga que someterse a esto para
conseguir dinero es algo humillante
porque es algo que en que es todos los
días y pues no sé es como de gastada
andrés alberga la esperanza de tener un
futuro mejor y tiene posibilidades de
lograrlo la corporación la está ayudando
a crear su propia empresa un salón de
belleza aunque el camino todavía es
largo
argentína vibra con el fútbol y en los
últimos años hubo un crecimiento en la
rama femenina pero la dirección técnica
es una área que no termina de abrirse a
las mujeres natalio coso de nos cuenta
un hecho como éste chocó profesión a
vallejos es una de las únicas dos
mujeres que hoy dirigen en los 19
equipos de la primera división femenina
del fútbol argentino
me preparé tuve la oportunidad de
desarrollarme 23 años en afa en el
fútbol como jugadora y bueno actualmente
soy una de las técnicas más jóvenes que
hay dentro de del femenino como casi
única mujer en este momento pero todavía
en sus condiciones no son las de sus
padres varones todavía estamos muy lejos
de lo que lo que es una primera división
vamos encaminadas estamos trabajando
para eso porque tenemos que estar a la
altura también es algo que también se ve
en lo futbolístico no tenemos el proceso
de formación que tiene un equipo del
masculino entonces estamos a años de
diferencia todavía en poder acortar esas
brechas que es lo que marca la
diferencia
en todo caso para las jugadoras es
importante que cada vez haya más mujeres
entrenadores es otra manera de tratarnos
me parece que es otro entendimiento
encima ya fue jugador así que también
nos no se entiende de ese lado tengo
claro que central también tiene en
cuenta en temas como el ciclo menstrual
que por ahí en otros plenos no me ha
tocado que es que se tengan en cuenta y
eso sin duda tiene la impronta de una
mujer que entienden nuestros procesos y
nuestro organismo
agustina quiere seguir los pasos de
roxana vallejos que puja por que las
oportunidades se abran para más mujeres
hay más de 150 entrenadoras que están
esperando su cupo y su oportunidad para
poder empezar a desarrollarse y eso está
bueno y ahí es donde nosotros estamos
trabajando para para demostrar que
realmente podemos y lo merecemos tener
un gran objetivo para roxana vallejos
sería dirigir el seleccionado nacional
de fútbol femenino pero por ahora tiene
como técnico a un hombre
en chile hace 25 años aún existía una
ley que impedía a las mujeres entrar en
yacimientos mineros además
supersticiones las dejaban reducidas al
servicio en los campamentos sin embargo
en la última década la fuerza laboral
femenina creció 50 por ciento en el
mayor exportador de cobre del mundo
patricia luna nos llevó a conocer la
historia de una de ellas
cynthia quiso ser minera desde niña y ha
vivido en primera persona el avance
imparable de la mujer en la minería
chilena y de otras mujeres
pero ahora cuando éramos más 260 mujeres
entramos ahora tenemos quieren jumbo
en cambio una gigante en mantención
en todo porque ahora se encuentran
mujeres entonces lomba están más
acostumbrados hoy cynthia es la primera
mujer en latinoamérica en obtener la
licencia de jumbos telecomandados una de
las complejas imaginarias fundamentales
en el proceso de extracción de cobre no
exento de numerosos riesgos y por
orgullo porque la primera museo de
proyección perdidas esto espero que la
primera de muchos y que esas puertas se
abran una mujer pueda lograr un equipo
en 2021 en esta mina se alcanzó la meta
de ciertos puntos y fuerza laboral
fueran mujeres más de 300 operan aquí
incluidos de la plantilla total de la
empresa estatal de codelco la mayor
exportadora de cobre del mundo son
mujeres pero llegar hasta aquí supuso
romper prejuicios como la superstición
de que no podían entrar en la mina
porque traían mala suerte y accidentes
por mucho tiempo hubieron varias
barreras de entrada al ingreso de
mujeres partiendo de ley es bastante
anacrónica de que mujeres no podían
trabajar en las operaciones hasta
pasando por sexos inconscientes de que
la minería no era un lugar para mujeres
en temas más estructurales como que
había muy pocas mujeres estudiando
carreras de stem o asociadas a la
minería familiares y amigos y están los
videos de presencia es un modelo más
para que las niñas del país puedan ver
que la minería no es solamente para
ganar es ocupar este otro nuevo espacio
del mundo tradicionalmente masculino es
una de las muchas conquistas femeninas
ocurridas en chile
y la boliviana sonia quispe es un
referente del empoderamiento en
construcción comenzó en las tareas más
sencillas y ahora su trabajo es
requerido en destacadas obras de la paz
acaba de asociarse con otras mujeres
albañiles para crear su propia empresa
reporte de emery vaca
con 39 años de vida y 10 en el oficio de
constructor a sonia quispe es un ejemplo
del avance femenino en un sector ocupado
en su mayoría por hombres dejó de ser
una peón a para convertirse en una
contratista ahora trabaja en la obra
fina de un futuro restaurante en un
nuevo centro comercial de la paz el
trabajo que ya que he sido poner cielos
rasos de drywall el puesto cerámica y
ahora estoy culminando con lo que es la
pintura no es habitual en el mundo de la
albañilería pero sonia es la maestra de
la obra y su esposo su orgulloso
ayudante la arquitecta que la supervisa
valora su empoderamiento como mujer
trabajadora calificada las mujeres no
desempeñado en estos goles y ahora
podemos verlos cotidianamente haciendo
este tipo de trabajo incluso con un
toque especial como es el de sol
para sonia lo más difícil como albañil
ha sido el esfuerzo físico y haber
sufrido lesiones a causa de accidentes
me ha costado me sigue costando porque
hay momentos hay cosas pesadas que se
alza así y yo a veces trabajo con mi
esposo para que me ayude no porque
lastimosamente estoy un poco mal también
de los riñones y tuve caídas de una
escalera
entonces me lastimado los hombros
las mujeres dedicadas a la construcción
generalmente son contratadas para barrer
mover tierra o carretillas y los
trabajos mejor pagados son para los
hombres para ayudar a cambiar esa
realidad sonia ha fundado con otras
mujeres su propia empresa si vamos a
estar
pero si vamos a estar constantes esto
puede surgir de armas
sonia y estas mujeres constructoras aún
tienen muchos desafíos por delante pero
están unidas para afrontarlos
y nos acompaña maría del pilar lópez
uribe economista e historiadora de la
universidad de los andes y pies y en
desarrollo económico del london school
of economics variedad el pilar gracias
los reportes que hemos visto hasta ahora
muestran dos realidades la dignificación
del trabajo pero también la vulneración
y la explotación las latinas estamos
cambiando nuestro destino a través de
los entornos laborales
hola muchísimas gracias por la
invitación y bueno viendo viendo estos
informes digamos 11 la percepción que
tiene es que igual siguen existiendo
discriminaciones contra la mujer en el
mercado laboral esto es esta
discriminación ha persistido y
obviamente es un importante obstáculo
para el empoderamiento económico social
y profesional de las mujeres si hemos
avanzado pero siento que hay tres
frentes donde todavía estamos un poquito
estamos un poquito rezagados en américa
latina' primero el tema de
discriminación salarial la
discriminación laboral de género es
donde es más evidente no en esto pues
solamente no necesariamente se explican
por las características siempre
observables sino que también en muchos
casos hay algunos elementos adicionales
como habilidades innatas motivaciones
decisiones de participar en el mercado
laboral que esto es esto es muy muy muy
importante y esto de hecho estas brechas
salariales es uno de los factores que
nos va a permitir un mayor avance en la
participación de las mujeres en américa
latina
en la menor participación en esta
asociada una salida por ejemplo el
mercado de mujeres casadas de un bajo
nivel educativo y en los contextos
laborales más vulnerables el segundo
gran obstáculo es el tema la
discriminación ocupacional que se da
tanto por segregación horizontal como
vertical dentro de las empresas por
ejemplo las mujeres tienden a permanecer
más en la base de las empresas en cargos
de menor movilidad con ritmos de
ascensos más lentos y por otro lado
están los techos de cristal que es el
digamos que también muestra una
desventaja muy amplia ante las barreras
invisibles que están enfrentando las
mujeres para alcanzar por ejemplo cargos
directivos que limiten su desarrollo
profesional y su empoderamiento
económico en temas de la segregación
horizontal las barreras son
principalmente socioculturales que
mantienen feminizados algunos cargos a
partir de unos estereotipos de género en
hila también digamos la segregación
horizontal también se da en los sectores
de construcción agricultura y transporte
principalmente que culturalmente han
sido labores dominadas por el género
masculino y que además facilitan esta
segregación es la brecha la brecha
salarial y finalmente diría que está el
tema de
la división sexual del trabajo los roles
de género división sexual del trabajo
que así que asignan roles
responsabilidades y tareas a las mujeres
por su condición de género se debe
analizar nuevamente dentro de este marco
discriminación salarial uco y
ocupacional estos roles determinan en
muchos casos digamos el conjunto de la
manera cómo se accede se utilizan y se
controlan los recursos y aunque las
mujeres participen dentro del mercado
laboral pues siempre se espera que ya
sean los principales responsables de las
tareas domésticas y el cuidado de
dependientes mientras que los hombres a
responsabilización del sustento
económico sin contar con los riesgos de
penalización por la maternidad que
siguen siendo muy reales en nuestra
cultura no pero por supuesto y ya ahí
entramos en un tema de los derechos
reproductivos que bueno lamentablemente
no tenemos el tiempo para ahondar esta
vez pero lo haremos más adelante gracias
a usted y vamos a hacer una pequeña
pausa pero ya volvemos con más de este
especial por el 8 de marzo en ellas hoy
[Música]
y continuamos con nuestro especial de
ellas hoy por el día internacional de la
mujer en brasil en las camioneros nos
llegan al 1% del gremio los hombres
dominan esta labor vital para la
economía del país más grande de américa
latina pero entre ellos destaca cleo
ribeiro que abrazó el volante a los 40
años informe de valeria saccone y
guilherme acevedo
el día de cleo empieza pronto eso sí a
pesar de la hora no puede faltar un
toque de rímel y el pintalabios antes de
salir para trabajar
vanderlei es el apodo de su fiel
compañero un camión de 15 metros desde
el que recorre las carreteras de brasil
tras los controles de rutina arranca una
jornada que se prevé larga
la pasión de cleo por el camión empezó
en su infancia durante los viajes en
autobús hasta el pueblo de su madre se
broker está pero siempre quería estar
cerca del conductor en cualquier
vehículo en el que estuviese muy pronto
me enamoré del tráfico a sus 56 años
tuvo que superar muchas pruebas para
hacer camión era inicialmente la
resistencia de su marido y después de la
sociedad
lloré mucho por causa de los prejuicios
me decían búscate otro empleo me decían
estás quitando el trabajo un padre de
familia pues era una vaga june paik yo
respondía yo acaso no soy madre de
familia uso mind familia man creo tiene
tres hijos adultos que siempre me
apoyaron incluso cuando hace 18 dejo la
peluquería para seguir su vocación el
soto mal de verdad yo me siento poder
siento mucha libertad poder hacer algo
que me gusta cuando era peluquera me
sentía muy atada adoro todo esto incluso
dormir aquí es agradable conocer otros
lugares nuevas personas cuáles y otros
lugares pues pienso webs pero no todo
son ventajas la fuerza física a veces
limita su trabajo aunque con este modelo
de camión es todo más fácil la
burocracia es otro desafío requiere una
dosis enorme de paciencia son muchas
horas a la espera de que las empresas
liberen las mercancías y hay otro
obstáculo la edad auto muy feliz es una
empresa que trabaja soy muy feliz en mi
empresa porque me aceptó en mis
condiciones actuales una señora gordita
con enseña con una estética que no se
corresponde con el patrón de belleza
actual drone porque el camión no es una
cuestión de belleza y si de destreza
la sociedad siria tiene una
configuración patriarcal pero más de 10
años de guerra han obligado a cambios de
fondo para la supervivencia cada vez más
mujeres asumen tareas fuera del hogar y
en líbano uno de los mayores países
receptores de refugiados frecuentemente
lideran los campamentos informe de tell
bonet y diego ibarra sánchez
puede parecer cualquier otro los
campamentos a lo largo del valle de la
bekáa pero éste a diferencia de los
otros está dirigido por una mujer maneja
baja bebé bajo el doctor es una shauis
como se le conoce a quien gobierna en
los campamentos una figura
tradicionalmente masculina pero con la
profunda crisis económica a creta días
al líbano los roles están cambiando
ahora las familias se alimentan
básicamente de pan no tenemos mucho más
las mujeres refugiadas han empezado a
trabajar fuera del ámbito del hogar y
hemos demostrado que podemos hacer mucho
más que cuidar a nuestros hijos jim se
encarga de toda la logística y la
gestión para el funcionamiento en los
campamentos de que se cumplan las
medidas sanitarias para prevención de la
comida y de escuchar las necesidades
desde la comunidad las dificultades
económicas han empujado a más mujeres
del campamento a asumir
responsabilidades y liderazgos fuera del
núcleo familiar no es un trabajo fácil
para ellas ante la falta de confianza en
sí mismas en una sociedad acostumbrada a
la autoridad del hombre con los hombres
no estaban bien como trabajadores
humanitarios estamos apoyando distintas
actividades para el empoderamiento de la
mujer y así romper ese círculo vicioso
de pobreza y dominio patriarcal en los
campamentos en
la ciudad
baja también es una shauis y en su
campamento está motivando atrás
refugiadas para que aprendan a leer ya
escribir
ya las chicas tienen que casarse y ya
está nada de estudiar aquí nos sentimos
más independientes cuantas más
refugiadas sepamos leer y escribir más
utilizaremos para la comunidad un boceto
new life un vídeo busway cinema ya han
roto las barreras de género una sociedad
campa te alcal como la silla
estas mujeres inspiran a las nuevas
generaciones a seguir sus pasos y
contribuir a la igual entre hombres y
mujeres en el futuro de siria y turquía
es el país de europa en el que más
jóvenes menores de edad son forzadas a
casarse cerca del 15% de las turcas de
contraer matrimonio antes de los 18 años
de ley de mira lucha contra esta
práctica y adrià rocha nos cuenta su
historia
dile que te mires una mujer especial
etc
es la única mujer jefa de barrio en la
provincia de diyarbakir en el este de
turquía
y una de las regiones más conservadoras
del país su principal labor ha sido
luchar contra los matrimonios forzados e
infantiles
soy como la madre del barrio los vecinos
me ven como si fuese una hermana mayor
no me comporto como una mujer sino como
alguien de la familia y ellos me ven así
o no al baile le ríen mejor y lucha su
camino hasta aquí sin embargo no fue
fácil a los 14 años el padre de demi le
obligó a casarse con un extraño con
quien tuvo cuatro hijos al final logró
divorciarse
mi vida como casada se convirtió en una
pesadilla una pesadilla de principio a
fin abusos sexuales a una menor como era
yo a esta edad legalmente uno no se
puede casar hasta los 18 años se
considera que eres un niño comencé a
sufrir cada día como una pesadilla
de mir decidió presentarse a mutar para
evitar que más niñas ofrecen lo que ella
vivió según datos de varias
organizaciones el 15 por ciento de las
jóvenes turcas se casan antes de los 18
años y casi todas lo hacen forzosamente
según los expertos en acción también en
este marcador en esa onda que enuncia es
una denuncia
en esta región casi todos somos incluido
yo gente cuyas madres se han casado con
13 o 14 años si no cambiamos la
percepción de que las niñas son objetos
si seguimos como ahora no habrá forma de
solucionar esta problemática
antonio durante los últimos años está
jefa de barrio ha conseguido que 40
niñas de la ciudad no sean casadas a la
fuerza
queremos darle la mano a las niñas y a
los jóvenes porque son el futuro no
podemos permitir que una chica abandone
la escuela porque es forzada a casarse
una sociedad que no tiene infancia es
una sociedad bajo ya ha sido un trayecto
largo y lleno de insultos y amenazas
pero de mí no se deja intimidar en un
país donde los matrimonios infantiles
son aún comunes esta mujer todavía tiene
mucho trabajo por hacer
el índice de brecha de género del foro
económico mundial ubica a japón en el
puesto 120 de 156 países en un camino
lleno de obstáculos existen casos como
el de kayak o emprendedora y fundadora
de si queréis el informe desde luz a
medina y chucky hiawatha y aquiles
hardies kayak o texto chía lidera
proyectos tecnológicos y educativos para
generar impacto social todo un reto en
japón donde no es común ver a una mujer
en altos cargos gerenciales
y nacho y pretenden si
existe una tendencia a considerar mejor
a los hombres que a las mujeres no
sucede sólo desde la perspectiva
masculina también sucede desde la
perspectiva femenina es probable que
ellos están subestimando su propio valor
final respectivo por ser mujer cayaco
enfrenta problemas para conseguir
financiamiento
investment es muy difícil incluso a
nivel mundial sólo el 12 por ciento de
las mujeres en el mundo recibieron
financiamiento pero estar en japón es
aún más difícil
el multiplicador cardíaco recuerda su
primer entrenamiento laboral en japón
allí los dividieron en dos grupos
el entrenamiento fue específicamente
sobre cómo sostener una bandeja y cómo
servir un té con cierto ángulo de los
codos y cómo hacer una reverencia era
sobre hospitalidad pero si hablamos de
la hospitalidad en una institución
financiera creo que hombres y mujeres
deben recibir la misma capacitación y
comedia neuman sirve decir en ese
interín propiciar igualdad de
entrenamientos son los primeros pasos
para ver un cambio en japón si no usted
sea en roboré ex canal deep los robots
podrían reemplazar los trabajos de medio
tiempo muchos de ellos realizados por
mujer hijos
cuando esto suceda tenemos que darles
una capacitación adecuada training
enterpreneurship kayak on trabaja en el
cambio inspira a mujeres a desarrollar
habilidades tecnológicas para el futuro
y así poder ocupar altos cargos en un
país gobernado por
y para la despedida de este especial
está con nosotros son maría adelaida
palacio puerta subdirectora de la
corporación es sisma mujer psicóloga
abogada y magíster en estudios avanzados
y en derechos humanos manera de la edad
gracias por estar con nosotros y lo que
estamos viendo en estos reportes
lamentablemente no es un paisaje
especial es el día a día de todas las
mujeres en todas partes del mundo una
diversidad inmensa en las tareas que
ocupamos que deberían ser todas sin
discriminación pero eso no sucede lo
increíble es que las mujeres estamos
aportando para el desarrollo de las
sociedades de las comunidades y de
nuestros países pero no nos dejan porque
el desarrollo de una mujer es el
desarrollo de una sociedad
hola angela muchas gracias por la
invitación a esta conmemoración en un
día tan importante yo creo que estos
vídeos que presentan ustedes como
ejemplos de los roles que asumimos las
mujeres nos llevan a un debate muy
importante y es que salir al espacio de
lo elaborar el último tiene tres efectos
para la cultura que habitamos primero
elimina ese estereotipo de que las
mujeres tenemos un destino que está
limitado exclusivamente en el espacio de
lo íntimo y del cuidado segundo nos
estaba decía evidenciando que el debate
de lo público requiere la experiencia de
las mujeres y que todo lo que nosotros
hacemos nos permite a definir como la
manera que queremos vivir queremos
habitar esta sociedad en la que nos
encontramos hoy y tercero les está
garantizando a las mujeres autonomía
económica sabemos que uno de los
elementos que ha favorecido las
violencias basadas en género por ejemplo
como la violencia intrafamiliar es el
que las mujeres sean dependientes
económicas sin embargo muy bien lo dices
tú y es todavía hay muchísimo red yo
creo que uno de los elementos que hay
que considerar es que salida al espacio
laboral por salir al espacio laboral
necesitamos medidas más integrales y
creo que los estereotipos están en
varios varios estereotipos y obstáculos
están en varios lugares lo primero no
tenemos bien organizado el cuidado las
mujeres seguimos haciendo las labores de
cuidado no se ha eliminado la pobreza
del tiempo y además no se ha reconocido
que las mujeres no tenemos etiquetas
para las labores que tenemos que
realizar entonces creo que eliminando
esos obstáculos por supuesto podremos
avanzar a un mundo donde las mujeres en
los espacios laborales puedan tener
mayor autonomía y puedan contribuir a la
sociedad de una manera más y más
equitativa y más justa y ya pareciera
muy rápidamente me quiero quedar con su
mensaje sobre las violencias de género y
como el trabajo es una manera de teclear
las completamente y de raíz sin embargo
yo creo que usted está cansada de igual
que yo de escuchar que dicen que las
mujeres rompemos estereotipos porque
estamos haciendo un trabajo que
comúnmente ha sido un trabajo de hombres
y ahora las mujeres lo podemos hacer
como si eso fuera una felicitación
cuando debería ser lo normal y tendrían
que estarnos felicitando más bien por
alcanzar hitos en lo que hace todo el
mundo con igualdad
absolutamente creo que las mujeres
tenemos que abordar esos espacios sin
mimetizarnos en roles masculinos y eso
implica reconocer que las mujeres somos
víctimas de violencias que las mujeres
tenemos que conciliar el espacio público
de lo privado usualmente con los digamos
con coco con con nuestros trabajos y que
tenemos muchos retos en seguridad por
eso no es digamos fortuito que las
organizaciones de mujeres constantemente
estamos evidenciando los retos que en
los espacios laborales por ejemplo para
eliminar el acoso sexual para la
formalización para identificar que las
mujeres nos pagan menos para identificar
que somos víctimas de muchos
estereotipos que repiten ciclos de
violencia en el espacio de lo laboral
oiga qué vergüenza muchísimas gracias
maría de la edad por estar con nosotros
en estas especiales del 8 de marzo por
los derechos de la mujer y en ellos hoy
seguimos trabajando
365 días del año por visibilizar
nuestros derechos sigan en france24
[Música]